on this episode we talk about prepping
employees for leadership over staffing
some fairly grumpy about the jets loss
[Music]
yes
ask Gary B
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk this
is episode 156 of the ask gary vee show
india's a little under the weather
i'm also under the weather for my
football weather I'm really pissed
whatever I'm not only want to talk about
that much like I'm in a bad mood I'm in
a good mood there's a lot of good
there's plenty bad I don't know I could
go on the rant of like the dealings with
the Boston fans but what's that I am 6
or 6 on my prediction I hope you guys
are making money on this but uh yeah
yep yeah let's get into the show dan
asks how do you prepare employees
transitioning into a leadership role
when they've never managed people before
Dan I think one of the big mistakes a
lot of people make when running
organizations as me the CEO this company
is they eventually somebody gets into a
place where they're good enough they go
into a managerial role so they go from
being a Mason to an architect they no
longer do the due day in and day out
they don't have to architect people
doing it at scale and the CEO or the
business owner or the boss never put
that person in position along the way to
do that like I'm really curious how many
people have been are gonna watch this or
listen to this answer but it may it may
make them start rewinding a lot of their
day to day things that they may not
realize that I'm puppeting from here
because they're getting it told by their
bosses but a lot of people whether
you're an a you know an account manager
or a couch supervisor about to become a
account director or a group director
where you're managing more people
there's a lot of things I'm doing
changing the accounts you work on
changing the team that's underneath you
there's a lot of puppeteering going on
to really a lot of different of like
groups I want them to be a part of just
different little things that are
happening to create a proxy in a context
point and a data point on who they would
be if they were a manager and so I think
the answer to this question is I prep by
prepping them along the way
versus ripping off the band-aid and then
I hope they could be a manager you know
I think you've got a prep people and and
I think you've got to give them some
context points and put them in positions
to succeed and and really like know them
to know if they were babysitter's or the
head of their of their sorority or you
know how they roll
like really auditing them as human
beings three six the outside of the
context of just them being an employee
these are all very important parts and
if you can replicate some of the
versions that matter to you a lot of my
people I think are really capable of
being managers from a skill level but
they don't have the HR EQ they are to
Taipei they need to take a step back and
Zen a little bit to let their employees
breathe they need to realize they can't
impose their skills biggest mistake a
lot of managers make when they first
become managers is they try to turn
everybody underneath them into them
versus turning them into the best
version of themselves Jim asks where do
you see the health and wellness industry
going in the next five years Jim I think
it's much of the same that we've seen
over the last five years I think we've
never seen such growth and everybody
caring about their health I got caught
up into it
I think we're eating better than ever
we're more educated about food than ever
I think people working out more than
ever I think the vanity of Instagram and
selfies no but I think everybody here
wants to look better than they used to I
think we're becoming PR versions of
ourselves so I think people putting in
more work I mean especially with butts
you know with butts you could actually
put in the work like you can actually
make your butt better by putting in the
squat so I think people really focusing
on that
um that's clearly been a trend it's just
true you know and so and so I think I
think more than ever one other thing
back on a 360 point of view on this I'm
I am seeing an enormous meditation trend
growing in the US I will I will argue
that five years from now which is a long
time from tap today a lot more people
are doing meditation on an everyday
basis the way we probably sell yoga play
out the last 15 years so I see a lot a
lot more focus on longevity health and I
think what I like is because of
information exchange on the Internet
I think they're seeing a lot more
healthy ways to go about it I think if
you look at the 80s and early 90s a lot
of the ways that people wanted to get
younger was by having surgery um and I
think more and more people are trying to
actually do something about it
in their 20s 30s 40s I'm so impressed
with the health risk that the u.s.
health culture has exploded over the
last decade and I see much of the same
tripling down I think there's a lot of
upside in that space I think that means
a lot more scammy quick buck making
people are gonna join the space I think
we've seen that I think every fitness
guru now thinks they're an entrepreneur
and wants to sell their program or their
shake a lot of the same DNA that being
great at working out and disciplined map
to being an entrepreneur yet I find a
lot of people that are strong at working
out every day don't put the same vigor
and work into their business which I
find very intriguing so that's kind of
what I see happening Tim do you rock
were you sad did you watch a Jets game
yesterday yeah and you just started
really becoming a fan and that was a
weird feeling yeah did you notice
yourself carrying a lot more than you
thought yeah come on dude come on who do
you like in football cool so then does
that mean that you're also getting
sucked up a little bit into like you're
here all the time like when you don't
care you probably care a little more
about the Jets than you did before
because I'm sucking you in right right
and so like were you like ah too bad
India so did you like did you check the
score like how did you find out yes I
did you watch a little bit or did you
check the score amazing yeah and then
when you finally knew we lost you were
like oh darn I was like yeah and Stefan
how did you follow did you watch yeah I
would watch someone you know second
scores and then yeah I said cuz I school
scores fourth quarter and I was like oh
1716 chance
Tim asks you've joked about being
overstaffed
but what's the balance between hiring
for capacity and waste Tim that's a
great question for all of you that are
growing quickly I think one of the
things I think the most pride in is my
ability to have a pulse on my
organization from a sales top-line
revenue impact and on the bottom line
cost thing I think I grow businesses way
faster I do believe that if I end up
operating two more businesses if I have
four businesses in my career before I
die
that I've hyper grown I've two now in my
bag like really fast like old times like
really especially non technology
companies really fast I will be known I
mean I actually think my legacy as an
operator could be speed to victory I
think what I'm really good at is I have
disproportional understanding of the
pulse of what I'm selling and I'm
willing to bet right to the brink
because I don't need to take home a lot
of money like I've always left my own
monies and my own vices on the table to
reinvest back into my business which
allows me to over staff which means I'm
then ready for the new business that
comes in and I don't have to go crazy
finding the talent and so because I'm
trying to build culture sure you can
freelance and outsource less margin but
you can do better cash flow make more
profit but I want those people part of
my team and grow with them let them
learn the religion grow so I think
everybody's got their own balance but I
think it's completely predicated on your
stomach for for risk because it comes
with risk you don't want to over staff
then you lose an account then you have
to let people go then changes the vibe I
think it comes down to your salesmanship
ability can you always in a pinch sell
some more stuff out of nowhere and I
think that it comes down to to the
understanding of where your business is
positioned compared to the landscape
meaning I always knew that I'm ahead of
the market and the world's gonna come to
me a lot of our scopes are contracts for
2016 are growing very quickly because I
knew the world in 2009 would spend more
money on Facebook Twitter Tumblr
Pinterest Instagram snapchat or whatever
was there at the time you know the
current state of the internet so I'm
riding that wave it lets me bet a little
bit more
it's a pulse cadence feel taste thing
that allows me to get away with it but
oh
more than anything it's the balance of
your own selfish wants of your take-home
income versus how much you want to
reinvest in your business it's as simple
as that if you're running a business and
you're making a million dollars in
revenue and you have six hundred
thousand dollars in expenses you're
taking home four hundred thousand
dollars you could make it eight hundred
fifteen thousand dollars an expensive
take home 150 thousand and then know
that that extra investment will allow
you to make three million the next year
I believe in myself ultimately any
entrepreneur CEO or decision maker
that's taking money off the table I
believe is betting less on themselves
along the way and are playing a
short-term game to me the time I started
extracting dollars is when I believe
less and the growth of the company yeah
I want to ask how important is it to
create a new lane for yourself as an
entrepreneur it's not big is working for
you do you just carry on doing that even
if you have new ideas that you may want
to explore I guess the whole point is
how and when is a rebrand necessary
that's a great question great question
and and you obviously probably know that
I went through a rebrand to a lot of
people which was I was the wine guy I
became this business guy social media
guy whatever you want to call me I did
it in parallel I'm a very big believer
that all of you that have real passion
and belief that you have skilled to
create another lane should and I would
call it my version of an 80/20 rule I
would spend 80% down on what's working
for you but I would always have a 20%
lane for testing learning tasting
creating new revenue opportunities I do
that all the time within my business
manner tries a lot of things a lot of it
fails but holistically we win because
have 80 percents enough one could argue
that we would do a lot more business if
I went a hundred percent I would agree
with that but then that wouldn't open up
the capabilities we're gonna be the best
360 video agency in the world that was a
bet and an investment and so that's how
you have to play it out 8020 my friend
it's a great question for a lot of you
if you can keep 80% of your practicality
and execute there especially if you play
the way I do which is if you'd layer on
top more hours then you're kind of
getting a hundred over here and you're
getting that free 20% testing and you
can test one thing at a time in that 20%
so you know 12 18 24 months on that 20
on this that doesn't work try another
thing but I wouldn't break up that 20%
into four or five percents because you
need at least 20% of your energy to get
something going off the ground in the
way that works for me everybody's
different but that would be my directive
black and white answer to that question
Sarah asks how can a consumer soft goods
company capitalize on the exposure of
being in at department stores this
holiday season
Sarah great question you know a couple
things I think Twitter search is
incredible
so anybody mentioning a Macy's or a Saks
or a Bloomingdale's or any of the store
that you could be mentioning anybody
that mentions it anybody
that mentions that on Twitter for you to
jump in as you as a human or is the logo
of the company and engage with them not
for the right hook you know but find a
sweet or clever or interesting way to
mention that you're there you know you
can literally reply like somebody says
going to Macy's to shop you could
literally reply of like have a great
time we love them they you know we now
are there you know like like just like
or like our new home for the holiday
season if you stumble upon us let us
know or you make it cheeky and fun and
you say hey take a selfie with one of
our products and we can do something
cool and then you do a random contest
depends on how much you want to go from
right hook to a jab but I would mix in
the acknowledgement even if it's as
simple as like we're happy to be there
to have a good time there we're so
thankful for them you know something
that's a little more self-deprecating
and appreciative to the organization
that gave you distribution but I think
Twitter search is probably number one if
you have some ad dollars I would run it
against fans of that organization a lot
of people follow these department stores
for their coupons and deals on Facebook
or Instagram you can run some ads
against them because you know you're
there if you have a small test around
the zip codes if they're you're in 13
locations you can run add some monks
people that are most likely to buy that
product depending on interests within a
one-mile radius of that store because
you know they're probably going to that
store so there's some tactics you can do
there that would be an I would I would
use it for content like if you or any of
your sales people or anybody in your
organization or if just you I would buy
an expensive plane tickets and go to
different stores and take pictures with
the product showing that you're hustling
in Texas and New York and in San
Francisco so that could be a cool
for content you can make some periscopes
live from like you know like it's a very
problem and I'm planning on doing some
really cool [ __ ] with my books
distribution this year I think I'm gonna
go to a lot of Barnes and Nobles and
bookstores and just sign them and leave
Easter eggs and like I'm gonna pick a
page in the new book whatever is a white
page and I'm gonna come up with codes
that if you email me and take a selfie
that you actually bought that book that
you then win like d-roc for a year do
you rock even work for somebody else um
you know like stuff like that like cool
stuff like that so I think there's a lot
of clever things you can do those are
just a couple of I came off the top of
my head cool is that it that's the show
do we want Friday's show this week
alright so I'll be able to do my
prediction six or six guys did you make
some money then you bet this week you
know gamble I respect that
it's all I got grumpy see you do you
keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
[Music]
[Music]